hot breath how many songs do you have to
explore before you pick like the best
three
like what what would you say is like
your average between how many ideas i
have
first actually make it to the final like
special
wait repeat that one more time that you
kind of cut out a little bit of it so
like how many how much research goes
into it like
you pick those songs but how many songs
do you have to explore before you
pick the ones that are worth keeping
you have to pick the ones that are
popular and then you also have to figure
out where people are going to
push back on your thesis because we live
in an argumentative and opinionated
culture now so
i have to already know what you're going
to say about what i'm saying
and have something prepared for that
because everything
you know the first thing anyone and i
threw this around with a couple of
friends you know i bounced theories off
of
the comedians as well
and hey man what do you think about this
bit black people don't write patriotic
songs we talk about cities
yeah but what about living in america
that's patriotic
and i go yeah but james brown didn't
write that yeah but don't nobody know
that they just know that he did it so
it's his song no one cares about
songwriting
that's a fair point so now i have to
figure out a way to still
uphold my thesis while inserting living
in america and thank god the lyrics
saved you know saved that bit but you
know there's there's sometimes so you'll
do research and you won't get
i mean we're just talking about the bits
that are kept we're not talking about
the ones that
that get dropped and don't and they get
stuck in mud
that don't necessarily
go from here to here you know
because you can have it and it's like
like there's a there's a bit that i'm
trying to work about mass shootings i'm
not sure if i'm going to be able to do
it anymore because of what chappelle did
with his snl monologue regarding how
uh covet how the pandemic curbed mass
shootings
but you know the joke worked a lot but
this is terrible to say
but the joke worked a lot better when
mass shootings were more of a regular
occurrence in our country because they
were at the forefront
of people's minds but now they aren't we
still know about mass shootings but
they're not as publicized because we're
in an election year and you got all the
pandemic and it's only
30 minutes in a newscast so
that joke which i thought was climate
because there were so many mass
shootings happening over the past
five to ten years right there was a good
two or three a year enough to where
i could comfortably walk on stage and
say mass shooting and know that people
would be with me immediately where now
that was then the climate has changed
you know maybe it'll be different you
know once the
what's the uh vaccine hits or
whatever but
i think for the most part that's a bit
that i'm gonna have to figure out a way
to retool
to get back into it you know and
and i think it's for where that joke is
right now
it's a long walk to make a point that
i'm not even sure is worth even making
anymore
just in terms of how
the bit the bit as a whole is about
why racial profiling is good
and you start with that juxtaposition up
front and then you work your way back
to justified and how you have oh this
there's another thing it also ties in
all the caring
and just white people calling the police
on anybody looking suspicious and so
the basic premise that i'm trying to
drive towards is just about how
if you're gonna profile someone profile
if you want to stop mass shooting start
profiling the people who have these
up haircuts
8 out of 10 mass shooters have a
up haircut
so and when mass shootings happen the
first thing we do
is talk to his parents
and ask them why didn't they stop it
don't talk to his parents talk to the
barber the barber knew
the barber is the one and and so the
whole bit is just about blaming mass
shootings on barbers
gotcha perfectly fine bit pre-covert
perfectly fine but that's right now
that joke feels like a walk so it'll get
sent down to triple aaa
and maybe we'll strip it for parts and
it'll fit into something
else but it's not a bit like if i
started going back on stage tomorrow and
building my
hour i don't think i would
i don't think i would do that bit the
part of the and so
and so here's where gets up
right
so because i lose that part of the bit
the other part of the mass shooting bit
that is actually relevant and pertinent
and his climate
isn't strong enough because the barber
was the
at the end gotcha because the whole
front half of the bit
is about so without doing the bit
essentially so my child bit someone in
school but it was a retaliation bite
from another incident at school right
and when you're the parent of a child
that does something wrong
the school scrutinizes you as if you
taught your child to be violent
and you could do everything right as a
parent and your child still might
up and it instantly made me feel
sympathy for the parents of every mass
shooter
da and so in that bit
what i'm essentially doing is going
through
most of the mass shootings that have
happened in this country
and looking at how the parents were
treated in each
mass shooting and so when we talk about
research i had to go dig in the crates
almost 20 years in mass shootings in
this country and go
look the kid the kid at virginia tech um
the asian kid who shot up everybody at
virginia tech
uh 15 20 years ago his parents
literally did everything they possibly
could
to keep him out of trouble they sent him
to programs they
sent him to make sure that he was
talking to people
psychiatrist therapist he was doing all
of that
before he went and killed so the
there's this this idea that every kid
is hiding guns under the bed and mama
don't know
is fault so that's the argument i'm
trying to make
in that bit it's just about how we can
talk about mass shootings
but mass shooting good mass shooting bad
gun control no gun control here's the
third angle
all right mass shootings whatever but
can we stop acting like every single
parent
is the one who drove the kid to the
gunshot wow
and that's the angle that i choose to
approach mass shootings gotcha
and so but you support that thesis with
examples
of where parents do there's a ton
of parents who are fuck-ups
the kid who drove over in wisconsin and
killed two
um two uh black lives matter protesters
with the ar-15 drove over from illinois
whatever
his mama was the one that drove him to
there's definitely some up
parents
but that's not like i like every single
time it's the parent because here's the
shooting
the parents were doing this here's this
shooting the parents did this
here and so there was there was a
there's a there was a mass
shooter
i think it was in pittsburgh it wasn't
the synagogue um
it was a couple of months ago or i mean
a couple years ago
this guy was like 50 he was 46 i
think he was 46
when he um when he shot everybody right
and people were still trying to blame
his mom and
i'm like she's 70 bro like
she got him to 46 she did her job
you can't like you can't
blame her you can't blame a 70
year old for some a 46 year old did
that ain't how the game is supposed to
go but i don't get that
i don't get that punch line unless i go
and do all that goddamn research
but even still all of that stuff it's
just
a couple of funny quips because you're
still dealing with dead bodies you're
still saying the word mass shooting
which is just a
word for people but the barbershop
is the funniest part of that bit boom
all right and in my opinion the
barbershop doesn't work so if the
barbershop don't work
all that parenting got to go down
to aaa too until we can get a better
button
on the end of that whole run so
some jokes are great but they're just
not ready or just doesn't
fit you know it maybe it's the type of
joke when there's another mass shooting
that's the joke that i can
reassemble real quick and just throw up
online
from a club set not everything's going
to be on tv and be polished some shit's
got to just be
some chappelle 846 type
and whatever i hope that breaks down the
process a little more you know
that's kind of but that's kind of how i
try to construct oh yeah i mean you
just put on a writing masterclass right
there my friend